Hello
bitches,
man,
it,
you still have those yellow jerseys in
your house and you have to give them
back into.
No good.
Fuck them.
She put an instagram picture of them
every day.
That was.
Yeah,
that.
I'm not going to put that picture up
again.
That was a great picture though.
Oh,
you chilling on the couch at seven
Yellow Jersey.
He's on your wall.
I got,
I got a note for that one.
Well,
you're going to get nuked no matter what
you do.
Look.
But,
but I,
I look,
I mean they're up.
They're up and uh,
and,
and I'm proud of him.
I really am.
And I'm proud of.
And that's the thing too,
is that as weird as it is,
and as strange as it is,
that there's just a line through those
years as if they did not happen.
Man,
I,
I had,
I was paid to do a job,
right.
As messy as the job was,
whatever I was paid to do it.
And I did it.
Uh,
and I wanted to win.
I wanted to capture those memories for
myself and for my teammates.
And you can't,
nobody can take those away from me.
I still hold those memories it to
myself.
And um,
yeah,
it's,
it's had a complicated ending.
But,
um,
you know,
I still view those as victories and I
still view those memories as good
carrying around the lie and being
interrogated and questioned.
And it was that the hardest part about
all of it.
You know,
I was,
I was only interrogated there are
questioned with the press and,
and even,
um,
you know,
God,
if it would have been in this day and
age with,
with,
with twitter and facebook and social
media and it would've,
it would've been a thousand times worse.
I mean,
this was,
you know,
I mean,
this was in the late nineties.
think about that.
That was a long time ago.
And so the level of scrutiny while it
was high wasn't nearly as high as it
would have been today.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
once you dig in,
you know,
with these,
with these guys,
you're,
you're stuck.
So
once you finally came clean,
I mean,
obviously there was a lot of blowback,
but was there also a relief?
Um,
not,
not immediately.
Not immediately.
I mean,
I,
uh,
I get asked that a lot and I think
people,
um,
people expect me to say,
well,
you know,
it was just this,
it was just this huge relief off your
shoulders when you,
when you talk to oprah or,
or whatever you did,
that,
that you can now move forward and live
the life of an honest man and et Cetera,
et cetera.
But it's taken me.
Let me just sum it up.
I mean,
sitting here today,
having this conversation,
I would much prefer to have this
conversation than the one where I would
have lied to your fucking face 15 times,
10 years ago.
I'd much rather talk like this.
So that's,
that's a relief.
Um,
but,
you know,
it's not like I walked out of sitting
with Oprah and was like,
oh my God,
I feel amazing.
That was,
that wasn't asked weapon.
And uh,
so was it like there with Oprah?
She's asking,
she's drilling you,
asking you questions about that start.
She came out,
she came out hot,
yes or no,
yes or no other.
She did a good job.
She did a great job.
I thought she did a good job.
I thought it was very compelling.
Yep.
Because the way she structured the
beginning part of the conversation.
Yeah.
Especially if you're going to do
something like that on television.
You want to capture people and keep them
there.
You kind of have to approach it that
way.
I thought she did a good job.
I don't know that it wasn't well
received and I.
and in what way?
You mean people didn't like you
afterwards in that way?
I think there's two things.
Number one,
I,
I wasn't emotionally ready to do that
interview.
I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't in a place where I think that I
sit today where it's,
it,
it's,
it is a position of contrition and
understanding the tremendous sense of
betrayal that's out there.
Like my perception of that today is much
sharper than it was three years ago when
I sat with her,
the feds and other lawsuits forced my
hand.
I had to sit there with that because I
knew I was going to be sitting with her
or with you or with Tom Brokaw or I was
going to be sitting with a government
lawyer being deposed,
being videoed and being leaked.
So I said,
well,
I'm going to go.
I'm going to find the place that I'd
rather sit down and talk about this as
opposed to a grainy video that the
government leaks to the world and that's
your coming out party.
So I did that.
But the thing about Oprah is,
is aside from me just not being ready at
the time to do it,
you know,
people sensed that,
but most importantly for the diehard
cycling fans and sports fans,
I didn't say enough.
You didn't name names,
you didn't.
You didn't call anybody out.
It wasn't detailed enough.
You're holding back.
You're protecting people.
That's what they said.
That's a very small percentage of the
population for the majority of the
population.
Those first five minutes was way too
much information.
They were like,
what the fuck did I just hear?
Like blood bags,
Hipo,
testosterone transfusions,
cheating.
It was way too much.
So you had people that were at one camp,
a smaller camp said he didn't say
anything.
He's holding back here.
The other campus,
like that's,
that's more than I needed to hear.
And so everybody was pissed.
Well,
I don't know why they would think it's
too much.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't understand that logic because it
is reality or a grandma in Duluth.
Right.
And,
and you and you support it.
The cancer survivor clause isn't real
and you hear that.
I mean,
you're sitting there going,
uh,
I don't,
I don't like anything about this.
So the,
uh,
so I see because they were also
supporting lives drawn.
Also supporting,
but the story,
how much of an effect did it have like
almost immediately on your foundation or
a donor?
Because I was asked to leave the before
that.
And so now I haven't been back.
So I,
I don't know and I'm not,
and I don't ask,
is it still around?
Yeah,
yeah,
but it must have taken a devastating,
I think so.
I mean it takes a hit in terms of
obviously in terms of fundraising,
which directly leads to its,
you know,
its effectiveness in terms of helping
create change for cancer survivors were
all around the world.
You need to raise money in order to do
that.
Um,
staff layoffs.
Uh,
I mean,
you name it.
I mean it's a but,
but I don't,
I don't have specifics because once I
left the board and left the organization
and they legally changed the name,
I mean,
I don't know.